oh hi Michelle hi love how are you this
hair honey life giving me all sorts of
life
thank you so much it was professionally
done and this color is so good I'm so
happy to see you wait do you have an
audience there right now yes we do hey
audience
you told Whoopi that you are dating
again how is it going you know I'm
rooting for you I love talking about
dating you know we always talk about
dating Michelle because it's such a fun
Rich subject everybody's looking for
love and it could be in the form of many
different things but people need and
want love in their life and they could
have kind of the same with the holidays
you know is it with family is it with
friends is it with your husband or wife
or you know how and where are you
finding love but dating is sort of a
perennial fun subject to discuss so I'm
just going on dates again and that feels
good because I kind of shutter down for
a while you did like I take I take
breaks you know and then I'm like you
know what I'm ready to try this again
and then I take breaks and I'm like I'm
ready to try this again so it the switch
is on okay anybody interesting and have
there been any multiple dates second
thirds those type of things there's been
a second and a third uh with someone
which is like a big deal because I feel
like usually it's one and done because I
see their behavior and I'm like this
isn't this is a non-negotiable this is
not a match
um so I yeah there was a second and a
third date with someone but yeah I'm
just I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm sort of open to
the idea again because I I hibernate
like a bear yeah you know in my dating
life like I will turn off the app I will
not have it in my world does anybody
else do that where you sort of like you
have on and off Seasons I feel like I'm
having it on season but I have to say
even bad dates are awesome they're funny
and don't let them get you down don't
take it as a sign that the dating is
hard or not functional that is one
person they don't reflect other people
and it makes for a great essay or
girlfriend fodder over cocktails or
whatever you're into
just always always stay hopeful you know
never become cynical and jaded really
about anything but especially dating I
think the dating Chronicles are always
rich and interesting okay I don't know
if the audience saw this just then but I
certainly did peep this when you talked
about the second and third there was a
little twinkle in the eye there was a
little look I think I'm just I was just
glad I made it to a second and third
with someone you know but it's I'm not
you know I'm not with anybody I just you
know I feel hopeful and optimistic
um I think also when you do have a few
bad First Dates you start to think I'll
never get to that second and third you
know Gwen Stefani came on this show and
she said something that really freaked
me out to my core in the coolest way
ever she had said that she thought at
one point in her life that she was never
gonna find love again I was like I'm
gonna wake up every day I'm gonna have a
coffee I'm gonna
take care of my kids and then I'm gonna
go to bed like I'm Never Gonna Kiss
anyone like I'm never gonna you know
what I mean like I thought my life was
over and then she did she found love so
there's like a happy ending there and
they just seemed like such an amazing
couple so fairy tale and and Fantastical
and yet it's real so it gives us all
hope that if a woman like her could
think that maybe it's a little less
insane that we've all felt that way and
she did end up finding someone which is
again a reason to celebrate when you're
single because somebody's gonna come in
there and sweep you off your feet and
then that time will be gone and you'll
be living with somebody else and you
need enjoy the time before that happens
I'm always so happy to see you but
especially during the holidays I'm a big
holiday freak and so what are your plans
do you have anything special that any
Traditions that you do with the girls I
always take them on a trip every
Christmas and I don't get them presents
which I think at their ages they don't
love
um but I say I think we'll remember the
place and the photos and the experience
and like that's what I want to give you
um and you know they get plenty of
things throughout the year so I'm not
like you know some weird strict cold mom
who's like you don't get any gifts I'm
just like I feel like a better gift
would be a life memory and I'd rather
invest it in this and then somewhere in
like May I'm like maybe I should say yes
to like a doll house or something you
know why
so it all evens out and it's fine
um but I really like to travel for
Christmas I like that too because it
could be stressful and I wish I would
have read your magazine piece before I
started stressing for the holidays
because you talked about the stress of
having like this picture-perfect holiday
last night I had a little bit of a
breakdown because I was trying to do
this tree and the Garland on the
railings wasn't getting right and I was
just like about to lose my mind so how
can we get rid of that pressure I think
that is exactly what the issue is about
it's a holiday issue that's sort of
anti-stress
um and you know we have a news story
today about how 50 percent of people
would actually love for the holidays to
last longer I think people love the
holidays we enjoy the holidays but I
think you know it's kind of the same
with like if we're having a good moment
with the show I want to talk about the
fact that we had hard moments for two
years with this show and I don't don't
just like the positive story I like the
scars the imperfections and the sort of
messiness of it all so if you do have
something positive I like when it's hard
one not because it came easily because I
don't think that's the Journey of life
and I think for the holidays I've spent
ones alone I don't have a family I've
tried to create weird bizarre traditions
and now I have kids and I'm getting that
chapter and to remember that one holiday
won't be probably the same as one ten
years from now that your life can
dramatically change and new people and
New Traditions can come into it and so I
like looking at the holidays through
like a comedic realistic lens of we're
gonna have a lot of different holiday
stories what one do you want to keep
going and build as a tradition rather
than this is my tradition and I'm stuck
in it you also talked about freeing
yourself from the dysfunction and the
guilt of drinking so how as you put it
slaying that dragon now improved your
life you know I'm not sober I don't work
a program so I don't want anyone to
think I do however yeah it was one
aspect of my life that wasn't
functioning and I didn't have Mastery
over it and I struggled with it
throughout my life and then finally just
saying you know what I'm going to cut
this out completely because I think when
you have crippling habits you sort of
think one day I will Master this so I'm
going to keep it in my world until I
figure it out only to spend decades
going I'm not figuring this out and it's
not serving me and then when you finally
change the biggest Liberation happened
for me because drinking was synonymous
with like you don't have this together
and you're not good at this therefore
you're a failure failure and you're
messy and the second I took it out it
was like oh you're capable of change you
can conquer things you can break cycles
and the narrative was so different and
for me it was drinking but it could be
something very different for someone
else but it's the behavior I'm
interested in and I didn't want to
become fully sober and like change my
entire life I wanted to take out an
element of it that wasn't working for me
and then it showed that I wasn't a
prisoner to something because I was
putting myself in that prison no one
else was doing it to me that's another
kind of amazing Revelation is when
something is very dysfunctional in your
life why is it and who's doing it to you
is it you
you have the capability of changing that
and if it's someone else
maybe that distance but the distance is
from the behavior I think as I'm getting
older behavior is sort of everything to
me yeah it's like my North Star even
like with dating I'm like what are they
how do they behave what what like you
know somebody's like he's so hot I'm
like yeah but does he behave well
[Music]